موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اعلنت فنلندا انها ستنضم بشكل
رسمي الى حلف الناتو اليوم الثلاثاء واكد
الامين العام للحلف في جانسيس
تصبح دوله كامله العضويه في الحلف اعتبارا
من اليوم وستشارك في جميع اجتماعاته واضاف
ان هذه الخطوه ستجعل حلفا نيت واقوى
من جيته وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
على المحورين الغربي والشمالي الغربي ردا
على انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو واقل جروسكو
انه جرى الاعلان عن بعض الاجراءات التي من
شانها ان تقوي امكانات روسيا العسكريه على
هذين المحورين في حال نشر قوات ومعدات من
قبل اعضاء الاخرين
بنيتو في فنلندا
يمثل او يمثل الرئيس الامريكي والسابق
دونالد ترامبا اليوم الثلاثاء امام
المحكمه في منهة بنيويورك في قضيه دفعه
ريشا لشراء صمت ممثله اباحيه قبيل
انتخابات 2016
واجتمع ترامب مع محاميها الذين اكدوا ان
موكلهم سيدفعوا ببراءته ونفى الناطق باسم
شرطه نيويورك وجود اي تهديدات امنيه جديه
واكدت سلطات الولايه ضمانها حق التعبير
بطرق السلميه
بطريقه غير قانونيه معلومات حول لائحه
اتهامه التي وصفها بالمثيره للشفقه واضفت
رامبا في بياننا تسريب المعلومات يستوجب
توجيها الاتهام للمدعي العام على الفور
اعلنت القياده العسكريه الوصله الامريكيه
مقتل القياديه في تنظيم الدوله اياد
الجبوري في قصف لقواتها امس في سوريا
واضافت ان اياد الجبوري كان مسؤولا عن
التخطيط لشن هجمات في اوروبا دون اعطاء
مزيد التفاصيل
قالت وكاله الانباء الرسميه السوريه سانا
ان مدنيين قتل في ضربه صاروخيه اسرائيليه
على موقع في محيط دمشق واضافت الوكاله هنا
الدفاعات الجويه تصدرت لاهداف في المجال
الجوي لدمشق وافادت بسماع يدوي فجره عده
في محيط العاصمه
قالت صحيفه اسرائيل اليوم المقربه من رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين التنياهو ان
اسرائيل
ستبقي قواتها على الجبهه الشماليه على
اهبه الاستعداد تحسبا لاي تطور لا سيما
بعد اعتراض طائره مسيره شمال طبريه اشرت
التحقيقات الاوليه الى انها ايرانيه الصنع
ونقلت الصحيفه عن مصادر صحفيه في اسرائيل
توقعها ان ترد تل ابيب على اطلاق الطائره
المسيره من الاراضي السوريه وان تعمل على
احباط اي محاولات مماثله في الايام
المقبله
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم قبل
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]